Chứ này nghen 1 tháng 5 năm, ngày hôm 20, mang tổ chức dài đuộng 1 tổ xanh trần cuối vui cuối xa,
ngày hôm 20, tài tình thương xác dẫn vẫn đồng vinh đi hoàn Quốc hiểu,
20 chiến tuổi đã từ vong sản 3 cùng ngày xó chính thương nạn sau tên anh khi thí đấu.
Chứ đó, khoảng 1 xóu dự bố biết phút hủ qua tại sinh tận động cân thơ, anh hiểu,
có đặc bộ bụng bụng có ai trắng 1 epsi thay trăm xấu mi hai tín,
và xử khu khí đang trên tầy vòng chúng kếc lựa dụng xe bố tì,
sự dụng xong xe ia mà hại xa tơ 1 năm không xe xe khi và cuối xu ba sẽ bất ngờ mất lại,
chính á hình tận động vinh và khỏi phương tị và đặc mạnh xú hoàn đường và hanzau.
Ná nhân được sự kiểu tại chố, sau đó, chuyển đến bệnh viện trong bình trạm đà trên thương nạn.
Ông chương công phía phó ra đốc sự văn hoá, thì thao và giữ tình phố cân thơ,
kiến phó vàn tổ chức cho biết miền bàn đầu được xanh định gió sự cố kiến thật,
khi quả kinh chá cho thế xe bị sự cố lúc của khi đồng cơ dựng đồ một dân đến tên á,
tình trạm này có thể xe xe xe và hình tất bụng cào đồng cơ của năm ông nói thiệt.
Thế bàn tổ chức chức xa đấu công tác kinh chá anh, anh toàn đường đua,
phương tị thí đấu đã được thực hiện thông quy định.
Hệ thống bảo vệ như phó hơi bao chấu sản chấn được bố xí đề đủ.
Tên nhân sự cố vấn xe xa xo đặc tụ tụng bụng cào và giữ gió của mua thi thao đồ xanh.
Sau sự cố, bàn tổ chức đã đến thăm viếng, chiến xe với gia đình bệnh đồng viên.